all the particles in this room those
that compose your bodies the photons in
the light and there is other things
things that make sound propagate phonons
etc are all quantum mechanical particles
and that means that most of their
properties are not sharp are not
definite quantum mechanical particles
exist in states where if you wanted to
measure some of the properties of these
particles most of times you would get an
answer of which you can only predict the
probability but is uncertain is
indefinite and for this property I will
use the word on sharpness this is
unsharp Nisour quantum systems and this
is what actually gives the appearance at
the macro scale of these definite
features that we all can see so let's
take a look classically what we know is
that objects have definite properties so
for example if you want to describe a
neutron you can for instance say that a
neutron is in a particular position 0 or
it's in a different position 1 these two
positions are distinguishable you can
also assign an energy to the neutral and
lots of other properties spin etc and
they're all definite quantum
mechanically picture is completely
different there is a state where the
neutron is in position zero does it say
it where the neutron is in position 1
but also there is this particular state
here which I represent pictorially like
that where we can only predict the
probability for the neutron to be in
position 0 or 1 but the position is
unsharp and these states are called
super positions and notice that these
unsharp ness has nothing to do whereas
very little to do with stochastic
uncertainty
like when you throw a dice this is a
different type of and sharpness is
richer and this is why it's the key
property that powers all of quantum
mechanics features including those that
are used for quantum computers for
quantum cryptography and for pop for
properties like entanglement there are
extreme exotic and different for what we
perceive this on sharpness is mind
boggling